tonight is part two of our semi Slav
this is the complete semi Slav so we're
doing a multi-part series and kind of as
I expected you know we're doing the
Moran I thought maybe we could cover all
of the modern lines in today's lecture
nope
it's going to be two parts so we're just
going to be going over sort of the side
lines in the modern Moran before we come
on to the main line which we'll have to
do next week so we'll remind ourselves
of the position so we're just going to
catch up to what we started with last
week so we get a Slav and this triangle
means we got the semi Slav now and at
this part of the lecture we're only
looking at the movie three that's where
we are
and after the logical developing move
we're looking at the move Bishop to d3
which allows black to take and play the
move b5 and yesterday we looked at the
moves Bishop to b3 and Bishop to e2 but
this week we're going to look at the
mainline still go away I'm getting
attacked maybe I'm going crazy but you
can see it that means they might say
that home to it was pretty big it was
over there - all right so we're getting
attacked for this one and last week we
looked at a six which does allow the
bloomenfeld variation that we went into
and okay some people don't want to allow
that with black but today we're going to
look at the more modern move Bishop to
b7 and as Claudia here in the audience
did point out it was an idea that Marcin
had so Larson was a the pioneer of this
move and one of the points is well okay
obviously when we played a6 the point
was to play c5 and c5 still is the break
that we want to play because then our
bishop would be really nice on this
diagonal so we can try to do this
without playing the move a6 for example
we could play b4 kick the night away and
then place a 5 and we wouldn't have to
waste any time with our
upon move here on the flank so that's
what you're trying to achieve in this
variation and there's actually three
moves that we're going to look at in
this position if you remember the
general rule for these kinds of
positions that I sort of mentioned last
week if they play on the side they play
a pawn move to try to play c5 next in
general the best way is to you know
react in the center they play on the
flank you play in the center so this
would be that the typical response stays
six and if you know they develop a piece
in general in these types of positions
the main move is going to be to castle
which is indeed the main line and we'll
see that next week however I do want to
take a look at the movie for which okay
is a very playable move but it's not
supposed to give white a theoretical
advantage and also we want to look at a
move tonight that's unique to the Bishop
d7 line which is the move a3 just with
the simple idea of playing b4 and trying
to prevent you from playing c5 forever
okay this is uh okay that that doesn't
work in any lines where we play a six
because after a three we would just
simply play see five so a3 is an
interesting attempt to try to take
advantage of this move order by black
alright we'll start however with the
move key for this is where we'll begin
our journey tonight and okay so we want
to again we're trying to play the move
c5 so we want to play a move like b4 and
then after they move we're gonna play c5
playing a move like a six with the idea
of playing c5 is actually a bit too slow
in this position because here now White
has the move e5 and we'll just see sort
of the danger you can get into if you
play a little inaccurately even early on
as black and if you go to d5 very nice
looking square we can take and you'll
notice now that this Bishop is not a
very happy guy he's you know you got to
do some work to get him out of here and
white actually has two interesting plans
here so let's just I do want to show one
really quick miniature that happened in
this line I will just mention first that
the main line is to castle and okay
Weitz plans include just playing a three
before this is still an idea you can
also play moves like Bishop d2 Queenie
one and try to trade for the dark
squared Bishop we know how important
this guy is especially when black is
trying to defend so that's one of the
other plans that he might have also the
untested computer plan of just Queen d2
followed by be for a very computer like
but that's okay if you're a stock fish
that's your preference but I do want to
mention also a very interesting move
just to give you an idea of how
dangerous this actually can get in this
position there's also this interesting
unique move Knight to g5 which is a very
aggressive move and I want to show a
very quick game Joseph Rukavina versus
Jerry Hartung from 2010 and this game
ended very quickly so black took this
opportunity to toss in this check you
don't like it what did you want to play
anything else do you have a suggestion
you have to like it but it's a good move
because okay you need a defender okay so
you just want to play like here or
something maybe so I assume I can play
like h4 f4
Yeah right yeah just you can come into
pressure really quickly and a problem in
a line like this too is it's always
gonna be difficult even to play like f6
even if you castled got your Bishop
outplaying f6 is always hard because
with your bishop over here you're not
even defending a six as much so even if
you get the bishop out and you play
castle and play f6 you still might have
some weaknesses to worry about yeah
there's going to be all sorts of
sacrifices looming in this position and
in we're gonna see that in the game I
mean he got into trouble immediately
okay but he tossed this check in which
is audience doesn't like it but okay
this part is fine okay you misplace my
King fine and now h6 which might already
be a mistake do you see the attack
coming Bishop is going to take upon
eventually okay will you play Queen h5
oh okay seem sensible enough so there's
a pin so if I take here you'll take my
rook you're attacking f7 black decided
okay
I'll protect Queen e7 what's the problem
and so I'll ask the class what's the
problem at night of 7 in are okay so now
the game is over the point is if you
take back hopefully we see Bishop to g6
winning the Queen so in the game he
instead castled which doesn't help very
much because queen g6 and I mean Olga
Road just lead to mate here so yeah this
this didn't quite work out this attack
was way too fast so there's even some
really aggressive ideas but the point is
you don't want to play a move in this
position you know way too casual a move
like a six because if this guy does end
up getting trapped like white can get a
hue Muenster monster attack right from
the beginning if this guy gets trapped
behind all these pawns and you never get
to play the move c5 so that's the lesson
so instead to move b4 this is the main
move
and white almost always moves his knight
to where it's looking at the c5 square
and black plays c5 noise what's that oh
yeah so the knight goes here so it's
it's trying to get control over the c5
square because that's where black is
trying to play he wants to play c5 so
that the pawn is out of the way of the
bishop so that's you know sort of the
strategic fight here is over whether or
not you can play c5 and indeed that's
what black always plays in this position
c5 now the bishop is you got a nice open
diagonal also we're attacking this pawn
so we'll look at just the next two moves
okay 'if I've very typical of this
position and the night goes to the
middle d5 and so again kind of like
we're going to see in all these types of
positions this pawn on e5 can be a real
strength early on you know if you're a
lot of these attacks it's a really
important pond because neither of my
Knights can go 2 EPSA cuz you got that
pawn there and ok obviously as black
you're hoping in an endgame that'll
actually turn out to be a weakness
you're hoping eventually I start taking
here and you know attack your center and
your Center crumbles and if you're you
know your center falls apart then I'm
going to be doing pretty good as black
and there's actually two plans here for
white so what black should do depends on
what white decides to do here so there's
two plans ok the most principled
continuation is just a castle so we'll
come back and look at that but the other
idea is to take twice on c5 and one of
the points although we'll see it's not
as dangerous as it may seem at first is
if we get all these pieces out of the
way we may be able to use this Bishop on
this diagonal for example let's take and
after we do lots of taking here castling
again is the main move pull this look
just for a second at Bishop to b5 which
seems ok very very good move right
you're attacking the
I don't have a good way to block but you
can actually get away with here to move
king e7 and we've seen in these
positions that's often where this king
wants to go so notice you're not really
worried about it move like Bishop to g5
which could be scary I mean you'd be
forced to play a move like f6 but
something like this is not as scary as
it may seem black here is actually
trying to play a move like Queen b6
which would attack a couple things if
this move it depends on where this
Bishop is and in certain lines sometimes
it's a double tax sometimes you go to b6
and you the bishop has to move and you
can get your books into the game pretty
quickly so it's actually not as as bad
as it might seem and we've seen in a lot
of games where that's just where the
King goes in a lot of these lines so
we're not actually afraid to stay in the
center and not be able to castle
okay so instead white should castle and
now we have to be really careful here
with black if for example we castle
which I'm kind of surprised this
position has been played like a hundred
times but nobody's ever made this
mistake yeah so there's yeah this is a
great gift when you see this trio of
pieces and I'll draw some pretty arrows
that have no instructional value but
they make the picture look better just
to show you that okay when these pieces
are lined up like this very often there
is a great gift
how you doing Orlando okay and indeed
here in this position it just works
because now if you go back anywhere
Queen h5 and if here Queen c2 this is
okay this is the end of the game so you
do have to be worried you know so in
this in these types of positions black
should play a move like h6 this is just
a typical move that you want to play in
this position which not only it takes
more control over g5 it also prevents
any great gifts that might happen so now
black can castle okay and from here
there's actually two plans for white and
so kind of during this lecture you'll
notice it keeps branching off and
branching off which is why you know it's
going to take several days to cover
of these lines but I think all the ideas
are generally easy to understand once
you you've started playing these
positions and we're going to look at two
moves here for White Queen e2 which is
you know just a developing move and also
the move Knight to d2 and then often you
bring a piece either the knight or the
bishop to e4 depends on what black
decides to do let's look first at Queen
e2 ok Queen b6 and okay we're not even
we're still not worried about this check
and after some move will even
voluntarily go to e7 so something like
this just doesn't really cause black a
whole lot of problems we'll just show
generally here's how you can develop
your pieces you bring your rooks to the
center the King can castle manually
something like this is just perfectly
fine for black okay so you might get a
position like this is so sometimes they
try to be a little more crafty here as
white in this position and they play
Knight to d2 and here again black now
has a choice between two moves and we'll
look very briefly at two games from both
of these lines because I know it's kind
of sometimes nice just to see some games
in these lines the most popular move is
to Castle okay very good move
my personal preference and I've actually
had this position at least once in a
tournament game is the move Queen to c7
okay so I'm delaying castling for a
while there's pressure on the e pawn
after let's say we defend our pawn I
want to look at the game Kuzmin Dre of
from saint-petersburg
2004 and in this game black just got a
very comfortable advantage and what he
wants to do over the next couple of
moves is he wants to bring his rook to
d8 you'll notice there's you know lots
of potential targets here on the D file
so there goes the d8 then the knight is
going to go to e7 in some order and then
the knight will be out of the way of the
rook and the
bishop and okay this they should
coordinate pretty well here for black in
this game he decided to start with
Knight to e7 and after Queen to g4 we're
not worried at all about taking here so
instead he played rook to d8 why not
okay let's take it
I'll ask in the back of the room do you
know what black would play in this
position right yeah so we want to go
here and it's you know worse than that
because now my rook and my bishop are
coordinating on g2 so something like
this would actually be pretty
devastating for white also I'm on here
so yeah there's I don't want to move it
either square so something like this
actually would be really really bad for
the white king here it looks like you're
in a lot of trouble so that's why so
this is not a threat so that's why he
you know K white didn't take and and
black didn't have to respond he had time
for rip d8 so Bishop b4 and one of the
problems is for white this Bishop is so
awesome you know and just like in that
other line where the rook can come to g8
there's lots of coordination against the
black King these bishops are really
strong so white you know has an effort
here to try to get rid of that bishop
okay Fleck just commonly played Queen to
b6 now we have a threat here on f2 and
I'm not really worried about you taking
me because then my queen will go here
and those might be the same similar
types of tricks so he went back and
we'll just go a couple more moves here
just to see that he got a very
comfortable edge in this game okay with
after some reasonable moves here a
position like this occurred and okay in
this position we can already start
thinking that black might be better
because he's got the D file for his
rooks and so something like this would
be just a typical game I don't you know
and I'll show this to show all the
theory but just to give you guys a
general idea one of the things in this
position is these bishops really are
great
while that bishop they can crisscross so
these bishops actually are really great
there we go
so you know White has to try to do
something to neutralize blacks activity
so even black can get a really strong
attacking chances in these types of
positions I do want to briefly though to
mention one other game so that's castle
so not Queen to c7 let's let's castle
here
now the most common move Knight to e4
and we're going to look at the game
gelfand Aronian from moscow 2009 and
again we're not going to see the whole
game but we're just going to try to see
how white got a monster position in this
game okay you're attacking my bishop but
i can sneak into d4 I'm attacking your
epon which is hard to defend but white
now has this move Knight to d6 tax the
bishop
so black moved the bishop and now a semi
surprising move both blade there's a
discovery here
so I played check
okay so we take and we trade the bishops
and black played the main move this is
still theory even today f6 however now
we're going to see in a lot of these
lines one of the problems for black when
he plays this way again is this c6 pawn
so that's actually a weakness that costs
him the game and just to show you a few
more moves okay Y can take but you
decided to toss in this check first and
now he takes here okay something like
this and so it just seems even just
positionally it seems pretty good for
white because some of these pawns
you know are a little bit loose
obviously black still has some decent
coordination of his pieces so it's
nothing too dramatic but you guys go on
to kind of mess this game up in a second
and now white goes here with the idea of
sometimes taking here on h6 and in sort
of a strange turn of events black
allowed this I don't know if how clever
he thought he was letting this happen
like maybe he has some counter trick but
really there's not so okay taking here
on h6 was a mistake and black attacked
the Queen a couple times but the Queen
is actually perfectly safe here we still
have time to get rid of our pin now this
move also was a mistake and I'm not
actually sure why he didn't play the
best move here white actually has a very
strong move here and it wasn't played in
the game so here I do want to test the
audience I guess what would you guys
play here as white yeah men exceeded d1
this looks like a decent move like I saw
I'll take and play Bishop e8
96mm on someone your queen here yeah I
am attacking your queen I intend to take
her oh you can do better than this you
know that's just sort of like a normal
move but there's actually already a
tactic here and I'm not entirely sure
why you didn't see it because it's a one
move tactic right yeah yeah it's
understandable when they miss you know
super complicated computer only could
find moves but this seems like simple
enough what do you wanna play rook e1
okay and your your idea is taking my
rook so I could move my queen
can i trick you you want to take care I
don't know I don't know who's tricking
who in these positions yeah maybe this
didn't work out for me um I don't know
but I can always just move my rook right
let me move my rook
no no I mean this still looks pretty
good this looks pretty good for you 93
though this is right now yeah you do
have a lot of threats so yeah the Queen
moved away from protection of the bishop
so now there's this possible threat and
okay even if you play a move like Bishop
e8 which maybe is the the best move yeah
you can take here you take my queen I
take your queen with check so I'm not
entirely sure why he didn't play that in
the game instead he played Bishop g5 and
he won very technically in a long end
game where he exploited you know the e6
pawn is a weakness and okay that's again
that's something that can happen in
these lines if you have to play a move
like f6 in certain positions a lot of
the time this a six pawn can end up
being a weakness all the way into the
endgame so here that's a that's how this
game actually unfolded and it was a
thousand moves so we're not going to be
looking at it okay so let's now come
back to this position and we're going to
look at one more idea in tonight's class
let me just actually at that time so
we're look at this position one more
time and we're going to look at now
another idea for white to move a three
and again the idea is to play b4 and try
to prevent black from playing c5 in
black can actually choose he can allow
white to play b5 for example let me play
maybe not the best move but an okay move
well I can choose to allow white to play
b5 or black can decide to play B for
himself and we'll see that this is
actually the main line so you're trying
to play before so I played before and
beat you to it
and my next move might be c5 so we'll
come back to this I do want to look at
what happens if we just play a very
simple move although it does look kind
of slow and obviously this does allow
white to get the move b4 in so this
might not be the best for black but
yes you can't play c5 immediately in
this position because this pawn wouldn't
be protected so if I play here both
things can take here so I'll take it and
then you lost upon and yet again it's
always hard to with these long series
because that was sort of a focus in the
first week and you come in that week too
it's sometimes tough but we'll get
through it okay so let's just play six
not the best move just to see what
happens even if we allow white to play
the move before well now we can play the
move a5 so it's true we did waste two
turns which might actually be
significant so we'll come back and look
for an improvement but here's how a
typical position like this might happen
now we're going to play Bishop d6
getting our Bishop out we might play
Queen to the e7 we're going to go after
that pawn and you can get a position
like this okay this would be the
starting point for this line however
let's try to be a little craftier here
as black and let's say okay so knowing
that variation let me play in this
position Bishop to d8 or d6 sorry and if
you play before castling is actually the
main move if you play before now I play
a5 and I've saved a tempo and if the
same thing happens already in this
position I can play Queen d7 so I have
saved a turn and in a position like this
like as a good move here Knight to d5
and it may seem strange because after
you take we take back okay this may look
like it's potentially a you know weak
pawn that maybe in a thousand moves
White will take advantage of this
position is actually known to be pretty
good for black and it's it's not super
obvious how white will ever make
significant progress
find a way to get an advantage here and
it's actually black you might get a lot
of chances on the kingside for an attack
because that's now his pieces are over
there and all of whites pieces are on
the queenside looking at this pond and
there's lots of ways that we could
potentially gang up on that pond also
this night will decide which way he
wants to go you know you can go to
either one of these squares and this is
actually thought to be pretty good for
black so this is not something to be
worried about which is why in general if
you play this move order white and stead
castles and this would so this would be
one interesting way to play this
position however I do want to just get
to the main point here in this line and
look at this move be four because these
lines are actually very interesting
there's a lot of potential for for pawn
sex that can happen in this variation so
almost everybody plays Knight to e4 for
a while when this you know be what
became a thing they three move people
were taking here however this does
accelerate blacks development
so if castles c5 and it may seem kind of
strange because the bishop you know you
would really prefer your bishop to be on
this side of the pond but this is okay
for black let's say if you're white
you're trying to find some way to get an
advantage
well you've sort of trapped your own
Bishop out here so I'm going to go and
I'm going to get it but now we can play
the move a5 and so when you take this I
can take back with my a pond and when
you take with the rook I can take back
with my Queen and this is very fine for
black okay I got a nice battery on this
you know line I'm going to castle I got
c5 in this you know I got good control
over all these light squares here so
this line would be just fine for black
this is
you know very nice position for black
nothing to worry about so that's why
since white had no advantage in that
line they've begun to play the move
Knight to e4 so this is your best try to
get an advantage if this is a how you're
playing here is white okay and we can
take and we can take here and now things
get interesting because very often
y can just castle offering this pond and
so we'll we'll look at that if however
you take here seems normal enough I
still want to play c5 so after some
normal moves we develop I can protect my
bishop and play a move like c5 so if
this sort of thing happens then I
achieved my goal I got c5 in so in a
position like this black would be doing
just fine let's see so instead castles
and in this position I do want to look
at a game it will even flip it just for
fun
a very interesting game so this is the
the main focus of this lecture tonight
this is the game Carlsen Aronian from
Bilbao 2008 and in this game okay after
one developing move you know okay your
Bishop one back uh uh runyan got a
little greedy he decides to take it you
know why not I'll take it you know I'm a
grandmaster I'm up upon everything's
great so black played a5 okay three very
nice move and now white is actually
played a move so Carlsen
that's okay never been played before or
since mostly because people don't take
this pawn so you don't see this lot at
the high level but here he played a
fantastic move so this one move is what
the whole lecture is all about it's all
been leading up to this this moment so I
do want to at home you may want to pause
tried
if you can play like Carlson in this
position so your head and development
your castled black is not how do Carlson
exploit these factors and make good use
here of its initiative how did you how
do you do it
d5 yeah this is the kind of move that
you may think about but how many of us
would actually play it a fantastic move
you know putting a pond where it can be
taken four different ways which is
amazing you've seen this one right but
you know you are trying to get these
bishops into the game and you're going
to try to cause some disturbances so
essentially have a look at all four
moves in the game he took with his
knight which is fine move perhaps the
easiest to refute is taking here so
there's a couple of them that we can we
can just get rid of and this is one of
them do we know what a white would play
in this position yeah this should be
five check yeah and so again we see what
happens when this Bishop is on this
diagonal sometimes we do have to be
worried about this sort of a check here
King e7 doesn't really work because okay
his other bishops and other pieces
attacking me so you have to play move
like this and then ninety five yeah okay
even if you defend I can play like rook
c1 and take your bishop and then take
your knight or I can play Queen f3 or
any number of really good moves this
okay this obviously has been a complete
disaster here for black so taking with
the C pawn okay that one that one's
right out this one is a little less
obvious
okay positionally maybe I got I got
hanging pawns maybe not a very good
version of them but okay how are you
going to take advantage of that well one
way would be to play Knight d4 we're
going to start getting pressure on c6
and
here I think I don't know if it's
necessarily the best move I think the
trickiest move is the move Knight to f5
I so I don't know this this could all
have been prepped by Carlson so who
knows what he would have played maybe
what a play group Siwan or who knows
what he had prepared but this is the
trickiest because you have to play King
f8 or g6 which you don't wanna play
either of those moves is black because
if you Castle it's already over
you have the very strong move Knight
takes G so the point being if you take
now you've entered this pin and yeah
you're going to see these bishops and my
queen coming to get you
so something like this would be just
game over because I'm winning this and
checkmating you and you know so too many
bad things are happening I think you can
play d4 and then maybe you can give up
your queen maybe that would keep you
alive for a minute um okay so that would
be an obvious disaster so okay black
would have to play something different
King f8 or so maybe that's not so
palatable we don't want to play that way
taking what the Queen is okay this is
not such a bad move we will do some
combination here as white of Queenie 295
bringing our rooks in really fast but
black actually could have an okay
position in a line like this we'll just
show it rather briefly this is sort of
how this line might go and okay you know
black is up upon so white has a lot of
attacking potential so this is a very
interesting position so this way it was
was actually a quite interesting way to
take his way to take was also fine and
in this game even though we we sacked
upon here with white he doesn't
immediately you know get some awesome
winning tactic they would you know
really make the game amazing but he just
slowly develops lots of pressure and in
this position okay he goes after c6 and
then black decides just
give it to them you get a position like
this where again okay we can't play here
because of the rook hanging you have to
play our move like king e7 and okay
we've seen in a lot of these lines this
may be not such a bad deal because here
you know this the bishop is on this side
so there's not really any good chance of
attacking the King with the bishop from
here so and maybe this is fine maybe you
can play this way as black obviously
it's a little scary but I don't know
with best play maybe this should be fine
all right tax the Queen and we'll just
go a couple moves just to show the
amazing finish okay in here yeah so in
what white has really is just some
long-term compensation in the fact that
his pieces are always going to be active
and let's see
yes I think this here was a mistake okay
so now black is doing stuff in the
center and that's where his King is
Brooke takes on before yeah this is what
was played but yeah now it's pretty
scary for the black King but here too he
played a great move so I think this also
would be I think it's really challenged
if you play this move then you're
winning winning winning but again he
must have seen this already I don't
think that it's entirely the easiest
thing to play so pause your videos at
home I'll give the audience a chance
here what's the best move here Carlson
did find it he did he did there's a very
good move perhaps not an obvious one
rook d6 it's interesting but I'll take
it
is there did you have more to it than
this
no just guessing yeah just give you a
rook away so Carlsen didn't just give
his rook away he didn't give his Queen
away yeah if it's a good move and you're
not giving your pieces away what chance
do you have to find it yeah and those
can be the hardest moves to find in
chess when it's not some sacrifice it's
just some really good move and once you
see it you'll say oh yeah that's really
good move but yeah finding it it's not
so easy so I do want to we got a lot of
firepower on the side of the room so
hopefully we can we can come up with it
efore that minimum I can trade the rooks
first well yeah up here maybe here's
good
maybe so okay I don't think I can take
the bishop but maybe I can I can defend
a little better like this
I'm trying to keep control over d6 I
think you can do better than this
before is interesting g4 that's the
craziest move you could play okay you
want to open that side of the board fine
how do you want to take it what all
right well I'm still gonna take this
first you're gonna take back presumably
who knows what you play I'll let you
paint cuz you're gonna play something
ridiculous no no this is not the way
forward this is Queen c6 okay right this
is very tempting move but I think after
King f5 I'm actually running away that's
where I want to go I get that f5 is not
the dream square but that is the general
direction that I want to go so here this
is actually fine but it's it's obviously
a tempting move but you can do better so
hopefully you guys found it at home in
this position Carlsen played mm-hmm you
wanna play Bishop d5 I take it or with
the rook which way to want to get no
good okay yes we did find the best move
here no so yeah in a position like this
and there might actually already be some
tactics here looking at ya
but at home they still don't know yet so
the problem with taking a pond like this
is it doesn't really have anything to do
with attacking the king and upon is not
the most important feature in this
position it's you know how weak the king
is because here I can actually trade and
then now I think I can take here because
if you check me I run away so I mean
something like this I think is is fine I
think I want a piece it's still scary to
be black but the pawn is really not
important in a position like this
because it's okay this guy is getting
attack
then there's all these tactical
liabilities and so yeah he did play will
Claudio came up with this was the hint
that I hope helped people rook to a1
rook to a1 and the rook can come into
the game a couple different ways and
okay now the position is just crushing
because if I play rook a6 then I like my
chances so he defended okay but now he
decides just to win some stuff and here
he wins stuff okay and so they traded
and now he went on to win and now it's
just a simple technical task if you're
you know Magnus Carlsen who for us is
right now playing in the World
Championship and that third round game
might still be going on because they
were there and play that forever do you
know what happened they know what
happened they knew like weeks and weeks
ago because this is never going out of
this me out like a month but anyway
that's the the game here that was played
okay a fantastic idea and okay let's
just let's just take one last look and
marvel at the brilliance here it all
comes back to this okay I'm down upon so
I need to get even more activity and to
sacrifice upon in such dramatic fashion
okay you can take it a thousand ways but
white in every line gets some sort of
compensation for the pawn
was it just a truly fantastic idea and
it can show you what can go wrong if
you're black and you try to get too
greedy in these types of lines so
hopefully that gives you an introduction
to some of the the side lines in the
modern Moran next week we will be
covering the main line in this position
which is to Castle so for that come back
next week go ahead hit like share
subscribe and I look forward to seeing
you guys next week